Good morning, John! It is May the sixth, the
day after my awesome birthday. Thank you everyone
for my awesome birthday. I got a Jayne hat.
I also got an anglerfish hat; it's got an
anglerfish thing up there.
So basically here's how my birthday went:
I slept in. And then I got up and I checked
Twitter and I discovered that Helen Hunt had
tweeted at me that she had seen my videos
and also that the restraining order that she's
sending at me is decorated with little flowers
and smiley faces.
Then I watched Henry being adorable and then
I chatted with you for a while and then I
saw lots of amazing videos from Nerdfighteria.
Thank you Nerdfighteria, you're so nice.
And then I went and I checked my mail, and
in my mail was a letter from the IRS telling
me that I didn't pay enough taxes in 2009.
So I owe them a lot of money and I don't know
whether to believe them or not because I thought
I paid the right amount of taxes in 2009.
So that wasn't my favorite part of my birthday.
But then the Fedex guy came, and he had a
giant box, and that giant box was full of
all the amazing things that nerdfighters got
for me.
Like my Jayne hat and this taco dinner kit.
Also this chubby little Hank Green Kyootee.
Isn't he cute? He's got corn dogs and a guitar.
DFTBA duct tape wallet. Tiny knitted rocket!
Kshooo! And also a little magnet with nerdfighter
hands. Basically all kinds of awesome stuff.
Too many words. He he he he he. I just made
him hump my face. That is weird. DFTBA pop-up.
Whaaaaat! This is an entire deck of playing
cards made out of duct tape, which is just
insane. And it came in a box made of duct
tape. I, eh, you can make anything from duct
tape. So amazing card. So amazing card! This
one doesn't look like much from the outside,
but on the inside, it's amazing! What the
frick!? I'm on a unicorn with a mushroom on
its butt, and there's a companion cube piñata,
and I'm hitting it with a lightsaber! More
Portal-based things. Helen Hunt in my birthday
cake; she's got corndogs for me.
And then probably the best birthday card not
of my birthday, but of all time: Humpy Hank
birthday card. And you can make him go at
different speeds, yeah, oh and fast. Or, check
this out, you can make him hump different
things. Humping Minecraft. No I don't wanna
hump Minecraft. Today I wanna hump a peep.
Hump the peep! No no no, how about a corn
dog. Hump the corn dog! So good. From Noxy,
thank you Noxy. Also in among all of those
birthday cards: giant wad of cash. And five
dollars in an origami star. Uh, that's just
amazing, I've never seen this before and I
like it. I'm gonna make it into a Christmas
ornament. But, I'm going to donate five other,
different dollars, uh, to charity for this
person.
If I didn't get your cards yet, uh, they are
still sending me more from Ohio. I'm very
excited to get them.
And thank you to Katherine, of course. She
got me a membership to the They Might Be Giants
fan club which I can't believe I haven't had
yet. So, woo!
And thank you, finally, to John, uh, for being
a great brother. I will see you on... Monday.
End screen time. Hello, Nerdfighters. After
a severe punishment drought, we now, uh, are
understanding what it means when it rains
and pours because now you have one punishment
for John not putting a video up on Wednesday,
and you have two punishments for getting Helen
Hunt to see the Helen Hunt video! That's three
punishments. Two for John and one for me - I'm
not flicking you off, that's the this one.
It's the not-flicky-offy one. So we need lots
of good punishment ideas. Down there is where
you put punishment ideas, in the comments
to this video. We are going to be reading
them. Please go through, also, if you have
time, and thumb up ones that you like so that
they will pop out. And we're looking forward
to having you punish - no we're not. DFTBA
and goodbye.